hello icons how are you oh my god thank
you
i'm good how are you so good i'm a
listen
i'm not so good i am so sad that this
series is coming to an end listen bibi
as an actor i can only imagine first of
all how grateful you are to you know be
part of a show like this but it's not
just any show this show has changed
lives it has changed perspectives so
tell me for you
how does it feel to be wrapping up
something that was so impactful for so
many people oh i mean it's super
bittersweet i mean obviously i'm so
thankful and and so humbled by the
experience and i'm i'm so grateful that
i was able to be a part of it and
um earlier on rachel and i were talking
about how like we always knew i think
that like the show was special but i
don't think we understood the scale like
how many people really were going to be
impacted on such a lovely positive
you know in such a lovely positive way
um so obviously i feel very very
grateful um
and it is really sad to you know be be
ending it off but you know i hope that
the fans and and everyone watching will
enjoy the the final season and
um you know it'll be like a big full
circle moment of you know
happiness and sadness and
excitement and
you know whatever it may be you hit the
nail on the head there with the word
bittersweet i think that's what it is
because this show has meant so much to
so many people but all good things must
come to an end at some point so rachel
tell me the time that you
read the final episode script for the
very first time
what did you think and tell me how fans
are going to feel i know we can't say
too much we don't want any spoilers but
how did you feel were you happy with how
things kind of wrap up
yeah i mean it's a journey that last
episode uh
so i think i was surprised and then i
was
sad and then i was just like
i don't know i felt kind of
at peace with it all and and really like
happy for these characters and
happy for their you know fictional
futures
um
and i yeah i hope fans are too
i think that they definitely will be and
bb it was
so nice because oftentimes i feel like
in
series that deal with anything queer
it's always very one thing and there is
a lot of trauma that is associated with
being queer and kind of finding out who
you are but bringing some bi visibility
to the show was also super important i
think so for you
uh i'm sure a lot of people reached out
and sent messages saying how impactful
it was
oh totally i mean i think it's exciting
because
um you know
we got little whispers of i think what
was to come for lake in the final
episode but people don't even know the
extent yet of like you know her journey
in in her sort of
understanding um you know parts of
herself that she hadn't necessarily uh
thought about before
um and so i i just can't wait to see you
know when people see it all what what
they have to say and and you know
representation is super important and
and the more people um that feel
represented on television the better so
um you know i'm very excited
all right so i love tea here at et
canada we like the tea and i'm gonna ask
you i'm gonna ask you both for a little
tea so i'll start with you rachel
who was the most emotional from the cast
on the final day of shooting was there
somebody that just could not keep it
together we should
i guess do we want to say at the same
time
anthony
see everybody said it was whoever else i
talked to said anthony t was so i was
like
he was actually as well both anthony's
were pretty both anthony's were super
quick coats
emo
well again congratulations on this
series it has been so important for so
many people around the world to feel
represented by i wish i had a show like
this when i was growing up and i think i
would have uh you know felt a lot more
comfortable
during those years so again it's great
to be on a show that is
an amazing show but it's also great to
be on a show that is really helping
people so congratulations on that and
happy pride
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos